Cuál es el escenario en este momento de
organizaciones criminales en Colombia De
qué tamaño serían esas negociaciones
para ese cc el fuego multilateral del
que Escucha vamos a hablar al presidente
Petro
Buen día importantísimo el anuncio que
hace este porque eso indica que lo que
estaba previsto por algunos algo para el
próximo año se va a participar ahí
intervienen organizaciones que se llaman
disidentes que no entraron o se
marginaron el proceso de las FARC el Ln
también el llamado clan del Golfo
herederos del panamericanismo son cerca
de 22
estructuras de este tipo que se han
pronunciado a favor de estas
conversaciones aparte de digamos de
otras menores y esto tendría un impacto
extraordinario en la sociedad colombiana
No es fácil porque son grupos muy
dispersos que no tienen un consolidados
mandos y no Son estructuras digamos
verticales unificadas pero
es es viable y sobre todo tendrá gran
impacto en la sociedad colombiana Señor
por eso precisamente al presidente
petrola han llovido muchas críticas por
un encuentro de representa de su
gobierno para incluir a disidencias de
la guerrilla de las Farc en esta nueva
Paz total cuando precisamente esos
detractores ya abandonaron el proceso de
paz que se firmó en 2016
últimas oportunidades No eso es una
obligación del estado de la sociedad
persistir Y en este momento se está
dando la posibilidad de de pasar una
nueva etapa en Colombia tenemos
experiencias se intentó y se se realizó
usted se multilateral en el año 84 donde
participaron en las farias m-19 lpl
otras organizaciones duró poco pero en
el marco de la Constituyente del 91 un
cese de hostilidades fue la antesana del
ingreso a la Constituyente y la
terminación del lanzamiento armado de
cuatro organizaciones de modo que hay
antecedentes y sobre todo hay una
urgencia
siguen los coletazos de una crisis de
violencia de asesinatos de masacres y
sobre todo una demanda de la sociedad
colombiana mayoritariamente hay una
revolución de conciencia en Colombia a
favor de la paz y por el fin de las
confrontaciones armadas y de la
violencia como instrumento de riqueza y
de poder qué supondría para el ejército
de Colombia en este momento es eventual
si es el fuego absoluto
no Por supuesto que eso establecerá
límites a la confrontación y a la
iniciativa militar Pero esto no quiere
decir impunidad
por la fuerza pública el ejército la
policía tienen que garantizar los
derechos de la población y tendrán que
estar listos para actuar Frente a
cualquier hecho de atentado en contra de
la población o en contra del mismo
compromiso de cc bilateral simultáneo o
multilateral al fuego y de hostilidades
que se llegue a pactar